[Music]
hey this is Steve with data lab welcome
to day 5 of our Alexa development series
for those of you that always forget to
do that to turn that off for those of
you that were here previously welcome
back and for anybody who's new welcome
today we are going to be turn that up
turn that off yeah today we're gonna be
talking about well first of all actually
if if anybody is planning on going to
the voice summit if you don't know about
it it is the largest tech event of the
year for voice development stuff if
anybody is planning to go there it's the
end of this month let me let me know I'd
love to to connect and say hello also if
you are planning to go or thinking of
going and you haven't gotten tickets we
you can go if you go to voice summit I
and register and use the there's a
discount code dabble da be ble that will
give you a 20% discount if you are
planning on going to that but let me
know if you're planning on going I'd
love to connect and say hello in person
ok today we are going to be talking
about multi turn dialogues and also data
persistence in dynamo DB and the
certification process I'm gonna I'm not
going to try to fit this into the free
code camp skill that we've been working
on just because I don't have a good
example for that and I really want to
try to make these two topics clear so
I'm going to use just I'm gonna go we're
gonna create two new skills to go
through each one of these topics so that
it doesn't get confusing hopefully
that's what I'm trying to to do with it
and and then we'll also talk about the
skill certification process we're not
quite ready to fully submit the free
code camps kill you
so I was hoping we might get a chance to
submit it for live review but we're not
gonna we're not gonna be able to do that
I don't think so
but we will talk about this skill
certification process so these are our
goals for today recap yesterday we
looked at using slots and we talked
about custom slots and entity resolution
yesterday and I think yesterday was a
lot got some feedback it what went kind
of quick for the time line we had and
although we got it all worked into the
skilled project part of the reason I
want to try to break these two topics
that we're gonna be talking about today
out is so that it's it's not as
confusing but we've got the we have the
repo now out there it's been out there
for two days but if you're just coming
back I will post the link to the there
you go that is the the github repo so if
you you want to grab the code it has
been updated
except for this link here I don't think
is the most current link I'll change
that though and we are ready ready to go
so we're gonna we're gonna start like I
said with multi turn dialogues and we're
gonna do that using the management
council so I'm gonna I'm gonna go over
to developer amazon.com and there's
there's kind of two ways that you can do
multi turn dialogues we talked yesterday
or the day before about what they were
multi turn dialogues are dialogues where
you're gonna go back and forth with
Alexa so you might ask Alexa for
something but before the intent can be
fulfilled Alexa's got to get more
information from your this skill does
and so there's sort of a back end force
so for example like ordering a pizza I
think is the example that I used when we
were talking about this before if you if
you had an intent that was a order pizza
intent to fulfill that intent you might
need the pizza size toppings all that
kind of good stuff and to get that you
would go
and go back and forth with a multi turn
dialogue to get the information that you
needed to fulfill the intent so that's
what we're gonna walk through I did a
tutorial on this a while back and I'm
going to use the the same example but
the example that we're gonna use is an
example for a like a sales coaching
skill so and I think that will work so
we're talking about the dialogue
interface I said there's two ways to do
this you can do it through the dialogue
interface which the the back-and-forth
is managed by the Alexa service you can
also look at within your skill code you
can look at the request and find out if
the slots have been filled or not and if
not then you can prompt the user with a
different response and that's gonna be
the second example that we're going to
show or talk about today and then with
that one I'm also gonna get into the
persistence part
so let's um let's get started
welcome back okay
what's the question free code can't by
any chance livestream voice 18 summit
will you be there I'm live stream of
Boise 18 I'm not sure what that is can
you can you post info on that so I'm not
sure I'm understanding that question but
I'll I'll get back and look at the
questions again in just a second here so
I'm gonna start a new skill and I'm
gonna call this Sales Coach and custom
skill
and for the skill service for the lambda
function for the backend I am going to
use the Bui tester which I'll show you
in just a second which is a great way to
to just kind of get a really quick
back-end setup for development stuff so
let me let me go do that right now
actually so if you to get the the if you
go to the github the Alexa github.com
slash Alexa there's a repo in there
called cookbook and it's got a lot of
cool examples and stuff in it so I would
encourage you to go check it out and I
from time to time just poke through
there and see what's in there and one of
those times I came across in the tools
folder this folder here this this here
this Bui testing tool and there's a
step-by-step walkthrough but and I'm
gonna just I'm gonna cheat a little bit
here for the walkthrough they they zip
up the project but there's a shortcut
way to do this that I'll show you so I'm
gonna go into the source code and grab
the code for this lambda function here
and what this does is just echoes back
requests that are coming from Alexa so
this is a skill service for really just
for testing and so oops so that's what
we're gonna be using it for so let me go
back over here to AWS now and to lambda
and the trick so you don't have to zip
it up and deploy it I'll show you what
you can do when you create your lambda
function for it if you use one of the
Alexa blueprints remember this
I guess day one now the Alexa blueprints
have the skills kit sdk in them so I'm
gonna just grab this one I'm gonna be
over writing all the code but I'm doing
this just so I don't have to zip and
upload and I'm gonna call this sales
coach that and basic execution roll is
good and then I'm gonna create the
function and like I said I'm gonna get
rid of all of the boilerplate code there
I'm just using this for the the SDK that
is included with it so I need to set up
my trigger there and let me get rid of
the code here
well while that's loading I'll set up
the trigger endpoint and I'm not talking
through all this because we had covered
this earlier but if you've got any
questions as I'm going through this
leave those and the in the chat and
we'll cover those actually I could just
disable this too but at that
[Music]
now why this is not pulling up the code
here
I don't know what it's doing there we go
alright and so then I'm just copying
oops I need I'm gonna just paste in this
here so copying it and then just pasting
this in like this so again this the code
that I'm copying and pasting in here is
just gonna echo back anything that it
gets from the Alexa service so it's just
for testing and I'm gonna save that and
I think we're good we need to grab the
AR n remember from earlier and then
we're gonna take the the amazon resource
name and add it to our skill endpoint
over here and we'll save that save the
endpoint some reason the trigger didn't
save
[Music]
let's see if that fixed it copy this to
the clipboard okay that time it's saved
so I think we're good yeah we'll just
leave it like that for now
okay so we're so we're good there now
now let's get into the the interaction
model and this is this is where we're
gonna spend the next few minutes talking
about the multi turn I'm gonna just set
the invocation name first to sales coach
save the model and now I'm gonna I'm
gonna create a an intent a custom intent
where that we're going to use is our
multi turn example so I'm gonna add an
intent called set goals intent and the
the reason I'm doing this with the the
UI you could do all of this with the
JSON editor but I'll show you the JSON
in a minute it can get it can get hard
to follow quick so if you're gonna use
the dialogue interface you probably want
to start at least doing it through the
graphical skill builder which is
actually really nice especially for for
doing this you can't of course do all
this in code and Jason and and deploy it
with the the CLI like we have been doing
up to this point but for this it'll be a
lot easier to show I think going through
the graphical user interface here so
first we need to set the sample
utterance and we'll just say set my
goals
and now this is where we're gonna get in
the multi turn so let's say that we want
to we're trying to figure out what the
user is gonna need to do for their sales
activity and so to do that we might want
to know like what's their sales goal for
the month what did they what's their
goal for the average value of a customer
and what's their goal for total
prospects that they're gonna contact and
then we could use that to to give them
maybe feedback that says this is what
your closing rates going to need to be
to hit your goal if your total revenue
goal is X and the average customer value
is why we're not going to do that part
because that's sort of outside the multi
turn part but that that's the idea
behind this so what we need is we need
their their total sales goal we need
their average customer value and we need
their total prospects contacted so so we
need three values that we're gonna
collect three values and for this
example all of the values are numbers so
we can use a built-in slot type there's
a number slot type and we'll use that
for all of them so the total sales is a
number the average customer value is a
number and then the total prospect
that's a number of them a change this to
[Music]
total prospects contacted okay so we go
back over here now what I need to do so
now I've got my my intent and I've got
my slots that I want to get information
on now I need to configure each one of
these slots so that well I've got some
options here so by default I can go down
here like this the the slots aren't
required by default but for this example
I'm gonna say - to fulfill this intent
to give them back some information about
how what their sales closing rate needs
to be I need all of those values so I'll
say that this slot total sales goal is
required and I'm gonna prompt them so if
the slot value doesn't come over with
the request or is not filled then I'm
gonna say what is your total sales goal
for the month and we'll just do one for
right now you might want to say that in
different ways just to make it less
redundant and repetitive and then the
user might respond and this is where i'm
gonna take the value that they provided
or this is the slot and then dollars
something like that or my my goal is
and then I would just like we we have
been doing you some additional samples
and then down here what I can do to make
sure that I've got the right response
from them I can confirm each slot and
I'm going to do that for just four for
this example okay and I'm gonna say
let's see so your goal for the month is
dollars did I hear that did I get that
right and this is where I'm looking for
a yes or a no to confirm this okay so
now I basically need to do the same
thing for each of these other slots so
the next one same thing I'm gonna
require this and I'm asking for the
customer value so what is the average
[Music]
value of a new sale
and maybe how much will the average
customer spend maybe something like that
this is an example and then the user is
gonna say something like dollars or the
average spend okay and we'll just go
with those two for right now and then we
want to require a confirmation so I'll
say I heard you say the customer will
spend do is right okay and then we've
got to do this one more time
and then we're gonna be good so same
thing here and what do we got
so total prospects how many
prospects will you need to contact to
get a single sale and then the user
might just say the UH number in this
case or maybe it'll say that with
prospects okay and then we're gonna
confirm this to you so you'll contact
is that right and then there we go okay
so now now we we have our dialogue
pretty much set up here let me show you
the the Jason editor show you what's
going on at this point so you can see
here that we've got our slots with the
samples and then we we've also got our
dialogue down here and this is why I
said this gets a little bit more
confusing because there's a ID that goes
with with each one of these which you
can manually create but I'm not going to
do that which is why I'm using it from
here and then you tie that ID to the
prompt that's going to come back for the
confirmation so if you're using the the
dialogue management you probably want to
do that like I said through through here
so we're just about done with this
example except for I'm gonna go back to
my intent to the the sales goal intent
here and I'm going to what am I gonna do
let's can we're gonna confirm that the
intent itself so we just went through
and we confirmed that we had the right
value for each one of the slots now that
we do we can confirm everything if we
want to do that and I might say so your
monthly goal is
your average customer will spend and
you'll contact tope prospects are you
good all right so so now once we've gone
through the entire dialog at the end
we're going to confirm the intent with
this here and so now I think we're
probably done let's save that and build
it and then we'll test it out so this is
gonna take a second here I'll read the
questions as I'm going through here
yeah I am that that's part of why I'm
gonna split this out Venkat I'm gonna do
separate separate skills today rather
than putting it all in the free code
camp skill because yeah I saw that I saw
that comment from you yesterday and I
think that's probably a good comment it
might be getting a little there might be
a little bit too much going on in there
so I will I'll separate it out today
especially for the next one that
persisting because that will have some
code this really doesn't have much code
so not a big deal but I think we are
ready to test let's give a try just need
to enable testing first
it's okay so I've got testing enabled
now I'm gonna just check I can't
remember what I used for my invocation I
think it was set my goals but let me
just confirm that
hmm I'll just try it
Alexa asked sales coach to set my goals
what is your total sales goal for the
month $5,000 I'm not sure what went
wrong
[Music]
Alexa asked sales coach to set my goals
what is your total sales goal for the
month $5,000 sorry something went wrong
let's see what went wrong oh this is
what went wrong I used the wrong
this isn't set yet so let me change that
[Music]
not sure how I ended up doing that when
I set that right but that is what's
wrong let me just make sure I didn't do
it on the other ones and then we'll
rebuild this average customer that looks
good
total prospects that looks good so I
have to build this again
so that's going to take a second
hey start-up Santana how are you doing
today
welcome back and look a Hey alright it's
almost done here buildind okay let's
give it a try again Alexa asked sales
coach to set my goals what is your total
sales goal for the month $5,000 so your
goal for the month is $5,000 did I get
that right yes how much will the average
customers spend $20 I heard you say the
average customer will spend $20 right
right
how many prospect will you need to
contact to get a single sale 500 so
you'll contact 500 prospects is that
right that's right so your monthly goal
is $5,000 your average customer will
spend $20 and you'll contact 500
prospects we good we're good your
endpoint received a request here's a
breakdown the request teca's intent
request Alexa stop me so that response
that I'm getting at the end there that
is the response that's coming from that
Bui test tool so the the back end skill
it's just like I said echoing back
everything that it that it heard or that
it got from the request so you can see
from this example that is a multi turn
dialogue using the dialogue management
so I didn't have to do anything to you
to in the code to do that so that's
that's one way of doing it the the other
way of doing it is to
actually look at the requests that are
coming over and that is in the code and
that is what we're gonna do next and I'm
going to I just I pushed out a template
on skilled templates I haven't published
a tutorial or anything on it but I
literally just pushed it out today for
this example because I I hadn't done
this example with the asked to Daddo SDK
yet so it's actually fumbling around
with it for a little bit but I think
I've got it all figured out now and so
it's the attributes starter template is
the one that we're gonna we're gonna use
so I'm going to come over here and this
one we're gonna do from code but I'm
gonna start with the the skill template
and show you what's going on in there so
let's let's go like this we'll go
[Music]
okay so it's this this template right
here the attributes starter and a couple
a couple of things in here that I'll go
over so for first of all the the basic
starter and if you just go ask new it
just uses the the core SDK so there's
the ask SDK - core and for this to work
you need to have the the full SDK so
that's one thing that's different in the
template this here so it's ask SDK and
then what's gonna what's gonna happen
here and this is a variation of the
basic starter template so the it's the
same kind of flow where it is gonna ask
you for your name and then down here in
when you respond when the user response
now here the the difference now is it's
going to use the attributes manager to
pull the attributes back so get the
persistent attributes and also to save
the attributes so what's happening here
is the very first time somebody responds
we get the name from the slot and in the
model again it's the same model and
everything as the the basic starter
template but here's the for the my name
intent here's the sample so they can
just respond with their name or Steve as
my name or my name is Steve or I am so
those are the examples so when that slot
the value for that slot comes over the
first time it's being set or being used
as part of the speech text but if if
it's not in the database so this is
going to be
persisted to dynamodb if it's not in
dynamo DB then we set the value of the
in attribute called name value here and
then we persist it back to the database
and what wires that up to happen is this
down here so this has changed also from
the the basic starter uses or if you
just use like ask new as the starting
point I think that's called like the
greeter template it uses custom here and
so this has changed to standard and then
you can add this with table name and
this is going to be the name of the
table that's created in dynamo DB and
you can change that to whatever and then
with Auto create is basically basically
saying you know go out and create the
DynamoDB table the thing with that is
you need to have permission to create
the to actually let me show you the
error and then I can talk through what's
going on there so um so let's let's
deploy this this
so I'm pushing this out yeah Ben can I
can share this code too if you want I
don't have this in a repo but actually I
mean this exact one but I'm not changing
anything from the skill template so you
can grab it from there but setting up
the permissions in Landa is it's got to
be done and I don't think I put that in
the readme on the skill templates
template I need to do that
I'm not sure if there will be a live
stream of voice summit I hope there is
I'll be there like I said so I'll try to
livestream some if I can I hope I hope
they're covering it I would I would
guess that they are but I don't know
that for sure okay so now if let's go
let's go back over here
Alexa open attribute starter there was a
problem with the requested skills
response okay so I've got add attribute
starter here but you can hear the the
error that I'm getting and I'll go
through remember how we did testing a
couple of days ago I'll go through that
process again just so you can see how
you would be bug it I know what the
error is because I've run into it but
I'll just step through the the process
again here so if you go to test and and
this is this is kind of the the easiest
way to debug if you're just getting
going but there's a lot lot better
debugging processes and if anybody is
interested in that the check out be
spoken tools they've got a really good
set of tools for for testing and
debugging but let me let me do this so
open
and you can see no output so we got an
error there but I'm gonna just copy the
request and go over here to my my lambda
functions and then here's the function
that was created for the attributes
starter hey Khalid alright let's see so
now so I'm gonna set up a test event
here and paste in that request that I
copied from the the developer portal and
I'll just call this launch request and
save it and then when I run the test
here I get more information you can also
look at the cloud watch logs like we did
earlier but I like doing it this way
seems quicker than digging through the
logs and so in here if I look at the the
error I can see it's the dynamodb
persistence adapters thrown in error and
it could not create the table alexa data
and this is because the roll doesn't
have permission to do that so that's
basically what's going on here so when
the when the asks CLI pushes out the
lambda function it also creates a role
for the function to run with and it uses
I think by default the basic execution
role as a template so in this case my
basic execution role does not have
permission to to create tables and
DynamoDB or any any of that stuff so
what I'm going to do is I'm
go to the role that was created for the
attribute starter which is this here and
you can tell because it names it the
same thing and I'm just gonna add
permissions to allow it to create the
the dynamodb table and I can do that by
just going attach policies and this is
loading here but I'm gonna find the the
dinette DynamoDB if you just searched
and I think for this I need the full
access so I'm gonna add full access I
could prob I could probably like modify
this this is probably more permission
that it needs it but for this I'm gonna
go ahead with it okay so now that I've
now that I've provided permission I
should be able to to try this again so
Alexa open attribute starter Alexa open
attribute starter what is your name
Steve Steve oh you know what hello what
it's nice to meet you
okay Alexa open attribute starter hello
what is your name
Steve I remember you you told me your
name was what so you can see what the
codes doing here is it's
it's saving the what the user says the
first time back to the the dynamodb
source that was created and let me show
you that actually to how we do yeah
we're good on time so if I go to
dynamodb here and go to tables and so
there there's the table that was created
there and if you go to items you can see
there's just this one record that was
created here and somebody was asking me
on the I think on the Alexus slack
channel yesterday or recently how the
how the records are associated with the
users and the answer is this there's a
unique user ID value that is the
associated with the the Amazon account
that's set up for the device I believe I
don't think it's unique to the user if
there's multiple users but I'm not 100%
sure on that but anyway it's that ID
that allows us to tie the information
back so if the next person comes in
that's using a different device or a
different account and does the same
thing then they would of course get you
know whatever value they said and you
can see the value here the property that
was set what if I change that here to
Steve
try it again
Alexa open attribute starter hello there
what is your name Steve I remember you
you told me your name was Steve yeah
so it's so it's pulling it here like
like you can see from the the Dynamo
back-end and it's pretty easy to to wire
up its the ask SDK one Oh was a little
bit easier it was literally like one
line so I had to fumble around a little
bit to get it working with the two dot
oh but I'll just walk through that again
now all the code is in now in the
attributes starter and the skill
templates but you need the the full SDK
first of all and then the second main
thing and and this is what stumped me
the longest is this by in the other
examples like if we look in to probably
even this one but any of the other
templates that I've looked at this is
custom here and so to to use that that
needed to be changed to standard and
then this with table name and then with
auto create table and with that all
wired up then you can use the like I
said earlier the persistence manager
attributes manager to to manage the
values to pull them back out of the back
end and to to save and there's now in it
there's now an adapter that you can use
so you can persist data or not an
adapter but with the persistence manager
you you can persist data to sources
other than DynamoDB also which I haven't
done yet myself I plan to play around
with that so maybe you want to save it
to like my sequel or CouchDB or [ __ ] or
something like that and that is an
option now using this but I haven't
tested
that out but I think that is pretty
close to what I wanted to cover for this
for attribute for saving attributes so
we've talked about let's see where we
are we talked about the multi turn
dialogues check data persistence we did
that demo and then the skill
certification process like I said we're
not gonna submit the the free code camp
skill today but let's go take a look at
that just got a couple more minutes here
so what we would do in the in the
process so if not if I'm hoping when we
submit this free code camp skill once
we've gone through it and we've tested
it and retested it ourselves and gotten
some beta testers and gotten feedback
and everybody says this is great let's
publish it out for the world to enjoy
then you would go over here to the
distribution
and and make sure that you've got
everything filled out here and we looked
at this is all in the skill man affected
the skill manifests of skill Jason which
is here so all this information but you
want to make sure that this is this all
filled out the example phrases your
icons are set your category is set you
probably want some some keywords here I
don't know if they're required or not
but you probably want to have those
definitely the privacy URLs and the
terms you are I know I'm almost positive
that privacy URL is required I'm pretty
sure terms are also and then you'll need
to answer these privacy and compliance
questions here so does the skill allow
users to make purchases or spend real
money and in our case no does it collect
personal information no is the skill
directed or targeting children no in our
case
although there's some smart kids out
there that are coding so maybe they
would want to check out free code camp
does the skill contain advertising and
no and then there's export compliance
here and then for the testing
instructions unless there's something
specific in there you need to do I
usually just say no special instructions
and then save and continue and then here
who should have access to this skill
public is the world you can also publish
skills for an organization through Alexa
for business and then you select where
you want the skill to be available so
the you want to select specific
countries you would just select the
countries or regions that you wanted it
available and Alexis not available in
all these regions yet but
I'm sure it's not far off so you want to
go ahead and select the regions that you
want and then save and continue and then
the the process it really depends on a
few things but you know how complex the
skill is and some other things but the
process Asian it's been pretty quick in
my experience a few days maybe and if
you do get rejected for or don't pass
certification for any reason the the
information that you get back is pretty
clear so it's really pretty quick to to
resolve the problem if there is a
problem and the last thing that I'll
show you and we are running up on our
time is the analytics and because we I
had sent this out to for beta testing
we've got some we've got some analytics
in here so over the last seven days
there's been 53 sessions and 162
utterances probably a lot of those are
mine during testing but I can see you
know a breakdown of which intents are
called and yeah get get some some good
metrics back on you know what's being
used and and what what the users are
most interested in and/or using most in
terms of the the intents and I think
that is gonna cover it that is our that
is it for today any questions let me
look down here how many elects related
slack channels are there there's really
just one that that I am familiar whether
I go to and it's Alexis slack calm and
it's pretty active you see its pull it
up here
yeah this is it actually here it's um
it's pretty active and so this is the
one that I I monitor and I am Steve T
here so if you if you have any questions
and/or
thoughts and you want to direct them to
me this is this is the one that I'm
looking at let's see any other questions
before we wrap it up and get ready for
the weekend that's okay it looks like
and looks like that's it well hey thanks
so much everybody I hope this was useful
and valuable to you if if you have any
other questions after the the live cast
is done you can leave those on the
youtube channel we also have if you not
subscribe to the data lab youtube
channel we've got I try to do like a new
video once a week it's not always once a
week but at least a few times a month so
if you go to youtube I'll pull it up
real quick
slash data lab and in the tutorials that
I'm working on right now are mostly
updating the ones that we're already out
there for the 2.0 SDK and I've got I've
got three or four of them that I'm just
about done with that I'm gonna start
publishing pretty quickly here and if
you're just getting going with this
stuff there's beginning node.js for
Alexa development kind of gets into the
node in JavaScript topics which is sort
of in the context of developing Alexa
skills but again I'm pushing stuff out
here trying to do that like once a week
and and yeah and the last thing is skill
templates comm if you go over here this
is this these are really mostly like
starter tap
and what I'm trying to do with skill
templates calm is put examples out that
are not not super complicated that are
really kind of focused on you know one
learning ideas so some of the really the
templates that are the examples that
Amazon provides are really good and
thorough but sometimes they can get
pretty complex especially if you're just
getting started so my my goal with these
templates is to make them as simple as
possible and you can subscribe here to
to get updates when there's new
templates published and I'm trying to do
a video with each one of the template
I'm and I haven't done that yet and and
yeah last thing if you're going to to
the voice summit or you want to go to
the boy summit go to voice I'm at AI and
hit me up on slack or YouTube or Twitter
and let me know that you're going I'd
love to connect and say hello in person
thanks so much again I hope you enjoyed
and have a great weekend
you
you
you
you